I
you
spotted wing Drosophila is a small
vinegar fly native to Japan it was first
seen in the United States when it was
noted in Hawaii in the 1980s the fly
reached the mainland in summer of two
thousand eight when it was brought to
central California during this first
year spotted wing caused an estimated
500 billion dollars in damages with some
farmers recording crop losses of up to
eighty percent the fly traveled across
the rest of the country and is now
widespread throughout the US and has
also been seen in parts of Europe
Australia New Zealand have imposed
quarantine restrictions on Washington
State cherries but as of yet no other
preventative measures are being taken to
guard against further spread of this
insect spotted wing was first seen New
York in the fall of 2011 but because the
fly is relatively new to the Northeast
their damage has been difficult to
quantify however since we are now aware
of the threat that the fly poses their
populations are being monitored spotted
wing is very similar to the fruit flies
that we are all familiar with however
these slides have a serrated ovipositor
allowing the females to lay eggs and
under ripe fruit unlike other disciple
of species which can only lay eggs in
overripe or rotting fruit females can
lay up to 16 eggs in one day and over
300 eggs in their lifetime which can be
up to nine weeks long studies have shown
that up to 13 generations of flies can
be produced per year and adults are
capable of overwintering a respiratory
horn also called a sting shown here
indicates the opposition site of the egg
eggs hatch within three days and larval
feeding immediately begins adulthood can
be reached after only eight days larval
feeding causes the collapse of fruit
tissue leaving the tell-tale
indentations and berries indicating that
the maggots are present this damage to
the skin of the fruit also makes it
vulnerable to bacterial and fungal and
section when further contains these eggs
is harvested within two days the maggots
will emerge making the product
completely unmarketable right now the
only way to control spotted wing is to
the use of full coverage sprays directed
towards controlling adult populations
there is currently nothing that can be
done to salvage fruit that already
contained developing eggs sprays must be
applied weekly and it is encouraged to
use a variety of insecticides with
different modes of action as a way of
preventing resistance however this is
not the ideal way to control a pest as
pesticide application here is based on a
time schedule as opposed to an IPM
approach this results in heavy spraying
which is both costly for farmers and bad
for the environment farmers are also
encouraged to closely monitor their
fruit and harvest it immediately once it
reaches ripeness and also to dispose of
infested fruit
the good news is that male flies become
sterile a 30 degree in that new york
state's natural cold temperatures may
help limit their population growth and
protect our fruit as scientists continue
to study spotted wing Drosophila and
make discovery such as this we will be
able to develop a better pest management
strategy for the future